the upper Moon one demon kukoshibo is
the second strongest living character in
all of Demon's Lair just behind the
Demon King moves on himself and in fact
his power is so incredibly overwhelming
that at the end of the manga it took
three of the strongest hashida to
finally defeat him however since he
actually used to be a Demon Slayer
himself I've always wondered what might
have happened if kokoshibo somehow Broke
Free of muzan's control and actually
became a good person and before
explaining how kukoshibu would actually
affect the ending of the story we first
have to ask the very vitally important
question of how would kokoshibo even
become good in the first place and
that's because he is currently still a
demon and it is normally impossible for
any demon to actually betray muzon and
in case you don't know that's because
muzan Cannon literally kill any other
demon with just a single thought however
the manga has shown us at times that
there are a few important exceptions
which we will be discussing in just a
moment and how they applied to him and
so I basically see two clear options for
how kokushibu could actually become
Goods the first most realistic option is
that he never turns into a demon in the
first place and fights muzan alongside
his brother 500 years in the past and
the second option involves tanjiro and
we'll discuss it in just a moment but in
case you forgot in chapter 174 of the
manga we actually learned that kokushibu
is actually the brother of the most
powerful Demon Slayer in history yorichi
and in fact the reason that kokoshibo
wanted to become a demon in the first
place was because at that time all of
the demon Slayers who had unlocked the
Demon Slayer Mark eventually ended up
dying by the time that they turned 25.
and of course kokoshibo didn't want to
die so when he encountered muzan he
actually agreed to become a demon in
order to survive however What If
kokoshibo instead had accepted his fate
remain a human and instead teamed up
with his brother to defeat muza that we
do know that yoruichi was very much
capable of defeating muzan on his own so
with the help of his brother who was a
powerful Demon Slayer in his own right
they should easily have been able to
defeat muzan right well that is
certainly possible we do have to
remember that as a human at least
kokoshibu was nowhere near the level of
his brother or the demon king and so
really I think he would have been a very
easy target for muzan which might
actually lead to yorichi being
distracted and getting killed trying to
save his brother which really is the
single possible worst outcome because
then tanjiro would have no chance of
actually learning Sun breathing and so
while this battle honestly could go
either way there is no guarantee that
kokushibu staying human and being a good
person helping his brother would somehow
allow them to take down the Demon King
right then and there and so with this
first option out of the way let's get to
the much much more interesting scenario
where kokoshibu plays a vital role in
taking down muzan towards the end of the
story and so in this scenario evil still
becomes a demon to survive the Demon's
Leia Mark's curse and I already know
there's people in the comments going
and you know that demons can betray
muzan oh yes that is normally true but
here are some exceptions for you one way
that kokoshibu could actually Break Free
is the same way this friendly doctor
Tamayo did in chapter 187 now while
we're not 100 exactly sure how this
happens Tamayo gained her Freedom
through some combination of her intense
hatred of muzan and the fact that muzan
was nearly killed by yorichi and so if
Toshiba also desperately wanted to be
free and muzan had another near-death
encounter with yorichi that I do think
that he could break out of muzan's
control as well or another option for
him to gain his freedom is also related
to Tamayo because as we will see early
on in the story she turned her assistant
yushiro into a demon all by herself now
this is important because yoshido has
never been under muzan's control in the
first place which means that if the
human kukushibo was looking for a way to
live and somehow encounter Tamayo then
she would most likely have been able to
turn him into a demon that's not under
muzan as well now of course both of
these options would require some luck
and changes to the story but that's kind
of the point of these scenario so let's
assume that kokoshibu is a demon but he
is completely free of muzon's control
now you do have to remember that there
is still a 500 year Gap and he isn't
strong enough to take on muzan himself
yet so what in the world is he gonna do
to help the current Demon Slayer well
for one he could work with Tamayo or he
could go into hiding by himself plus
there's also a very real possibility I
think that muzan would try to hunt down
kokoshibo himself but since Tamayo and
yoshido were able to hide for 500 years
so far let's assume that kokushibu could
manage that as well and so now let's
skip ahead through the centuries and
kokoshi will probably wouldn't reveal
himself unless he thought that there was
a very serious chance for him to defeat
Busan which probably wouldn't really
happen until tanziro and nizuko saved
Tamayo during the asaksar and it's very
possible that kokoshibo either just
Witnesses this event himself or maybe
tanayo just sends him a message about
this very interesting pair of siblings
but either way kokoshibu will be keeping
an eye on tanjiro and nizuko from here
on out which is going to absolutely
change everything when tanjiro first
reveals his ability to use Sun breathing
during his fight against the spider
demon rui which by the way what's a
legendary episode and at this moment
here Coco evil will finally feel some
hope that a new generation of demon
Slayers has arrived to take down Musa as
a result kokoshiba would probably decide
to finally reveal himself to tanziro now
or he might wait until the young Demon
Slayer unlocks the Demon Slayer Mark
during the Entertainment District Arc
but either way kokoshibu will meet with
tanziro very soon after that and
honestly meeting kokushibu would be
pretty terrifying for anyone I mean just
look at his face though I do suppose he
could change his form since he is such a
powerful demon nonetheless I do think
the best way for him to actually meet
tanjiro would be if Tamayo invited the
siblings to come visit that way
kokoshibu could reveal himself to
tanjiro while having Tamayo back up his
claims that he is actually a good Demon
and knowing tanjiro once kokoshibu has a
chance to explain who he is and that he
wants to take down muzan I really can
see him refusing the Demon's help given
everything that we know of tanjiro so
far however this next part of the
scenario has the potential to blow up
everything because when kokoshiba offers
to train tanjiro logically I don't think
that the young Demon Slayer would want
to keep this a secret from the Demon
Slayer core which basically means that
kokoshibo would first need to come to
the Demon Slayer headquarters so throw
500 years of hiding into the trash
because it's time for him to reveal
himself to the entire world so let's
assume that he agrees and the leader of
the demon Slater core kagaya uyashiki
actually allows him to come which is
also debatable honestly but this is
going to lead to a mind-blowing
encounter with all of the hashira
because remember that kokoshibo chose to
become a demon 500 years ago plus the
demon Slayers were nearly wiped out by
muzon during that era so obviously there
is
Bad Blood no matter what and when you
throw a certifiably
I don't think that any words would
really keep the wind hasida from
charging in and trying to chop
topushivo's head off right then and
there seriously just look at what he did
to nizago and she was just a little girl
now I don't think that there is any
chance that sanimi succeeds here
although it is fair to say that this
version of kokoshibo probably isn't
quite as powerful if he stopped eating
humans but regardless he would still be
an incredibly strong demon who has been
training for 500 years and it would
likely take multiple hashida to actually
take him down however I don't think that
kagaya would actually let that happen
since he was the one who invited
kokoship in the first place so after a
few sword clashes he orders the fighting
to stop immediately and for you to
subscribe to the channel for more Demon
Slayer content just like this but now
kokoshibu can finally explain who he is
and that he actually wants to take down
muzan as well and not just as a fighter
but honestly you would probably make a
much bigger difference as a teacher as
well because he could show them many of
the secrets of the old and original
Demon Slayer core this includes some
abilities that they already know about
such as total concentration breathing
but also others such as being able to
see the transparent world and even more
information about the Demon Slayer Mark
itself and boy this is going to
dramatically change the final Clash
against muzan as you can imagine however
I still don't think that many of the
hashira would actually want to be
training under a demon even if he was a
former Demon Slayer but I'm sure that
tanjiro at least would accept with
kagaya's approval especially because
kokoshibu could show him more about Sun
breathing since his brother was the one
who invented it 500 years ago and let's
be real zenitsu and inosuke would
probably also join into the training and
even though they might not be able to
unlock access to the transparent world
or the full Demon Slayer Mark just by
practicing I'm 100 sure that training
with a super strong 500 year old demon
would give all three of them an
incredible power boost early on going
into the next Arc and let's be real with
a greater Mastery of sun breathing and
total concentration breathing tanjito is
absolutely going to crush the demons
during the swordsmith village Arc in
fact I might go so far as to say that
tanjiro's new powers might even let him
take out the upper moon for a hunting
Goose True Body and his emotion-based
forms before they can even combine into
their strongest form and so when the
laugh hashira mitsuri and the missed
hashira murichiro see just how powerful
tanjiro has truly become since training
with kokoshibo I do think that this will
finally convince them that they should
probably also start learning from
kokoshibu as well I mean who knows maybe
at this point tanjiro would even be
strong enough to officially become a
hashira at this point as well which is
honestly just the start of how much this
good version of kokoshibo will change
the story but from this point let's
assume that muzan still finds out about
resistance to the Sun so the plot
progresses mostly unchanged from here
and this of course would lead to another
very intense training Arc before the
Demon Slayer core is then attacked by
muzan of course alongside the Demon King
are the remaining upper Moon demons
including a brand new demon since
kokoshibu is not on their side this time
as for who would be the upper New Moon
one could honestly go a few different
ways the easiest thing would obviously
just be for the old upper Moon two
Donuts would be simply promoted with
akaza moving up behind him as number two
or the other option is that muzan
convinces another strong Demon Slayer to
actually join his side and this new
demon then becomes upper Moon one in
fact if you'd be interested to see what
that would look like for any of the
harshitab let me know in the comments by
the way kokushibu's presence during the
final battle is going to change things
in so many ways of course the start of
the battle will go as usual since muzon
was able to catch the Demon's layers by
surprise very much though even in the
original story that means that still
talks with muzan and eventually blows
himself up then Tamayo poisons muzan and
at this point the demon Slayers arrive
along with kokoshibu and this is where
things start to go absolutely insane
muzan is of course Furious that multi
possible demons are siding with the
demon Slayers at this point and he's
especially pissed off when he recognizes
that kukoshibo is actually Yori ichi's
brother and so he probably just go
berserk and try to kill them all
instantly but since everyone here is now
way stronger because of their training
with kokushibu they can actually defend
against the attack without anyone
getting seriously hurt and then
kokoshibu might be able to actually
occupy muzan long enough for the other
demon Slayers to deal very significant
damage but I do think that in the end as
I mentioned earlier this version of
kokoshibu might be way weaker than in
the original story so they would
probably not be able to defeat muzan
right then and there but that's of
course just the beginning of the battle
because then muzan drops them into the
infinity Castle so that he can recover
from tamayo's Poison this splits up the
Demon's lairs to fight against the upper
Moon demons and here is where we have
some very interesting choices because as
you'll remember originally tanjiro and
the water hashiragyu fought against
fought against kokoshibo however since
kokoshibo is on the Demon Slayer core
side now one of two things here could
occur first kukushibu could just fight
against whatever new demon is the upper
Moon one and this is a bit tricky since
normally demons can't kill each other
with sunlight but let's assume that
kokoshibu can actually use nichirin
blade and can kill demons because that
would free up muchido genya and sanami
and kyome to help all of the others or
the other option is that these four
could still fight whatever new demon is
the upper Moon one while kokoshibo helps
fight some of the other stronger demons
but whatever the case there are way more
strong Fighters now here to help with
these battles so we could even see
people like shinobu and muichiro survive
the final battle this time and now by
this time yushiro forces everyone out of
the infinity castle and I think there is
a strong chance that almost all of the
hashira are actually still alive here
maybe only Genia dies but overall the
demon Slayers are in a much stronger
position to actually fight muzan for
round two and thanks to kokoshibo's
training now I think most of them would
be able to see the transparent World
which would greatly help them defend
against muzan's unbelievably fast
tentacle attacks which now of course
leads us to the Epic final Clash which
honestly is still going to be incredibly
difficult at this point there is still
an hour and a half until dawn and
honestly muzan May simply realize that
this situation is way too dangerous for
him and he might even try to run away
immediately to come back another time
however let's actually assume that he
decides to stay or that they somehow
managed to stop him from leaving that
means that they either need to delay
muzan until sunrise or cut through all
12 of his vital organs which you know
interestingly there are exactly 12
Fighters facing off against muzan if we
include all of these surviving demons
layers and kokoshibo so I can just
imagine an unbelievably epic final scene
with each of them destroying one of
luzan's organs together and in fact this
could even let us avoid the entire
tanjiro turning into a demon mess I mean
that was always kind of weird in the
first place which means that because
kukushibo now became good many more of
the were able to survive the final
battle but I do wonder if everyone could
have lived if another strong demon were
to join their side I'm actually talking
about demon rangoku and if you want to
know what would happen if rengoku
accepted akaza's offer to become a demon
you can watch that video right here
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one